this is a production of Cornell
University
alrighty good afternoon everybody I'm
Matthew Fenn I'm in the jovanoni lab and
I'd like to talk to you all a little bit
about my research looking at fruit color
variations specifically through the lens
of wild selenium relatives
so a few quick words on tomatoes the
Tomato was originally referred to as the
Tomato that is the new model word for
tomato tomato is unique in that it's
Center of origin which encompasses Peru
Ecuador and the Galapagos Islands is
distinct from its Center of
domestication which is up a little bit
northward in Central America its initial
range of cultivation might have extended
as far south or north as the
southwestern United States so modern day
New Mexico and Arizona
and currently tomato was regarded as a
vegetable crop I put that in quotes
because it's a fruit of global value now
not only is it something that's pretty
amenable to growth in the right field
conditions but it's also highly highly
tractable to growth in the greenhouse so
this makes it a global crop of Interest
furthermore tomato is valuable to us
because it's amenable to transformation
sorry
as well as tissue culture and it's also
inter-fertile with many wild solanum
relatives so not only is it an
economically important crop it is also a
valuable model species
now specifically my focus of interest in
tomato was looking at carotenoid
pigments carotenoids are a class of
pigments as the title says they're
pretty important and they're important
for a variety of reasons uh from the
human perspective first and foremost
carotenoids are nutritionally important
beta-carotene is a vitamin a precursor
necessary for proper vision and Immunity
likewise lycopene is an antioxidant in
addition to this carotenoid pigments are
also important for flavor and
aromobolidol synthesis which is pretty
impactful in consumer acceptability of
fruit Beyond tomato fruit quality Beyond
tomato
apocronoid metabolites underpin flavor
volatile symphysis and tomato as well as
melon and a variety of other soft fruits
and finally plant protection
xanthophyll pigments are involved in
protecting leaves as well as developing
fruit tissue when it's still in the
green stage from photo damage
now my means of exploring carotenoids
and carotenoid variation in tomato is
going to be assisted by the use of three
distinct breeding populations derived
from crosses with wild relatives so to
the bottom oh
Whoopsie Daisy oh I'm going in the
opposite direction here ah
bear with me everybody
ah
spoiler alert okay here's my laser
so here we have salon and
pimpanelatholium which is the red-footed
direct progenitor of cultivated tomato
um it's a fun plant I'm not going to be
looking at it the io populations I'm
looking at are derived from crosses with
the relative selenium fabricates solanum
like a presaquides and salon and
panellii these are really wonderful very
very hearty plants they are well suited
to growing an incredibly dry desert
conditions with high UV indices so
they're incredibly interesting to study
and as you can see from the phylogenetic
tree to the left here lycoprusocoides
which is right down here out of the
three ancestors it is the most
genetically distant from cultivated
tomato panelia and fabricates being
about genetically equidistant from
tomato
and now A Brief Review on what I mean
when I say an integration line
population integration lines are
distinct from recombinant inbred lines
and that one develops an integration
land population through a biparental
cross typically with a commercially
relevant recurrent parent and a wild
donor parent and then subsequent back
crossing of the F1 hybrid to the
commercially relevant recurrent parent
and what you get is a population that
yes has relatively low genetic
resolution and that these Integrations
are pretty large at times sometimes
spanning multiple megabases but you do
get a pretty nice sliding window of the
donor the wild parent genome in the
background of your commercial cultivar
now specifically my research question
and goals uh concern the following I
want to know which loci and or allelic
variants within and peripheral to the
carotenoid biosynthetic pathway mediate
carotenoid accumulation and profile
variation in tomato fruit and I just
want to specify that when I talk about
carotenoid profiles I am talking about
the concentrations of individual
pigments namely phytoine phytofluene
lycopene which is the most highly
accumulated pigment in Ripe Tomato
beta-carotene Alpha carotene and others
um so to this end I have leveraged
existing carotenoid and transcriptomic
data from these three populations in
order to identify specific Integrations
that are associated with instances of
carotenoid variation
and upon mapping these introgressions to
resolve genomic bins that contain
potential Regulators unique to or common
across populations I hope to
isolate or identify a potential
candidate loci using functional genomic
analysis
so a quick review of my methods I've got
echoey all of a sudden
um
so my genotyping has been done using a
single end RNA secrets so this is my
means through calling Snips and
identifying a specific integration
region boundaries
um specifically I used the genome
analysis toolkit pipeline gatk in order
to call Snips I should specify that
these populations which have been used
for quite a few years now have been
previously genotyped using caps and rfop
markers which while valuable in and of
themselves are a bit lower resolution
than calling snips
and in terms of my phenotypic data I
have acquired carotenoid profile data
for phytoine Alpha beta-carotene and
lycopene as well as others as I
mentioned a few minutes ago and I have
used this data to specifically identify
integration line individuals from each
population that displays statistically
significant variation in their
carotenoid profiles and I did this using
a post-talk test called the Nets test
and I want to draw everyone's attention
briefly to this insertion map here so
this is from the S peneli silin and
Pinelli IL population in blue you have
chromosomes 1 through 12 it's made up of
12 chromosomes and then in Black you
have uh basically Integrations so
Integrations as you can see overlap in
some cases and there are also gaps one
would create a bin map by delineating
the regions of overlap as well as the
gaps between each integration and that
is what I have done so we see here a bin
map I have for chromosome six uh it's
interrupted a little bit by the zoom
icon but whatever so I'd like to draw
everyone's attention to uh Bin 6f and I
also want to specify that these red bars
you see that represents an integration
so
so each integration here corresponds to
an integressed region from a wild donor
in this case like a persecutives and a
single individual in red I have like a
persecutives Integrations in yellow I
have pinellii intermissions
and so what we have here in bin 6f is an
enzyme called lycopene beta cyclase uh
tomato has multiple paralogs of lycopene
beta cyclase 3 to be exact I believe
this one is specifically expressed in
the chromoplast which is the organelle
that accumulates carotenoids
specifically and so what you see here
from looking at the the results of the
transcriptome data from these
populations is that the Leica
proseccoides and the panellii specific
lycopene beta cyclase is expressed far
higher fold in il individuals contained
in these isoforms than in individuals
that Express the wild type enzyme and so
this is pretty interesting and
unsurprisingly this results in a high
beta-carotene phenotype uh in the fruit
specifically
and I want to specify that lycopene beta
cyclase is involved as the name implies
conversion of lycopene to beta-carotene
so
um and noticing this variation in
expression I wanted to look at the
region Upstream of the start codon for
this enzyme
um I also did an alignment between the
amino acid sequence from the Tomato
specific like a persecutives and finale
specific lycopene beta cyclases
um and the enzyme is pretty well
conserved in terms of its amino acid
sequence there was it was around a 90 97
match
uh that is not the case for the Upstream
sequence which may contain potential
promoter sequences uh as Charlie did a
nice job explaining finding the exact
location of the promoter sequence can be
a bit tricky but as you can see here uh
relative to like a persicum there are a
number of insertions and deletions
sometimes comprising multiple base pairs
that are present in this Upstream region
and for your reference I also did want
to include some pictures of the fruit
il-6-3 is the IL is the high beta IL
line from the pinellii population you
can see it's pretty orange relative to
the wild type likewise 4254 is my IL
line of interest from the electorporst
equations population and it displays a
similar phenotype in that it is far more
orange far higher or higher beta keratin
accumulation relative to vf-36 which was
the recurrent parent used in that
population
and so finally I mentioned that I'm also
interested in potential loci residing
outside of the biosynthetic pathway
and now looking Instead at chromosome 5
and Zoning in on bins 5 app and 5G I
consulted the transcriptum data across
the three populations in order to find
potential genes of interest if anyone's
interested in my cutoff values or
criteria for selecting genes Based on
transcriptum data I can tell you but I
decided to look at a lower beta-carotene
and lutein phenotype and I selected
genes of Interest based upon whether or
not they have previously described
functions and also if they describe or
if they display a higher fold or lower
fold expression of greater than positive
or negative 0.5
and so a particular interest to me
are an R2 R3 MIB transcription Factor as
well as an slnap1 Knack family
transcription Factor so both of these
are of interest to me because MIB as
well as an acronym transcription factors
are known to regulate carotenoid
biosynthesis and overall ripening
progression respectively in tomato and
in particular this R2 R3 MIB
transcription factor I haven't shown the
number here but it displays a pretty
high correlation of around 0.95 with
lycopene beta cyclase which is the
enzyme I described on the previous slide
uh and likewise r2r3 map transcription
factors specifically subgroup 6 are
known to regulate flavonoids uh in some
instances in addition to carotenoids and
finally uh this slnap1 has been
described in a previous study to
influence chlorophyll degradation as
well as sugar accumulation and ripening
tomato fruits so both might be of
interest going forward
and finally next steps in future
directions uh are threefold I am in the
process of continuing my selection of
genes of Interest specifically and some
of you are going to laugh at how big
this size is but I'm looking at bins of
around a megabase or less hopefully uh
less work for me if they're less and I
specifically want bins that Encompass
three or more ILS and that have
consistent clean phenotypes
um I will refine my selection of genes
of Interest by looking at whether or not
they display correlation with pathway
enzyme expression and also if they have
previously described functions and
finally as I mentioned earlier I have a
goal of carrying a functional genomic
analysis with select genes of Interest
through crispr casinine and
viral-induced gene silencing with that I
would like to thank uh you all for your
attention as well as my lab giovannoni
Lab my committee and all collaborators I
should mention I forgot to add a a name
of one of our illustrious postdocs
Vincent colantonio is also a member of
our lab I thank him for his help as well
particularly in doing my alignments and
I would open I will open it now for
questions
so thank you
Charlie what would you use crispr versus
figs
um
so that's a good question so crispr
crispr is great in that you're able to
generate stably transformed lines vigs
would be good if I for instance find
that I have a high number of genes of
interest to test and I want to do
transient transformation instead of
going to the lengths of generating
stably transformed lines crispr is a
little bit more time intensive
um it has its perks in its drawbacks
viral induced gene silencing I could
generate a construct carrying potential
antisense sequences for multiple genes
um sometimes in combination and it it
could be a better large scale approach
um
ideally I'd like to integrate both and
so
um a fine mapping approach could be
taken with uh some of the other
resources that we have we have
carotenoid and transcriptome data for a
pimpanellifolian population and there's
also a backrest in Redline population
derived from the panel AI uh IO
population so that's something that
could be used to to supplement my
current approach
um and add some power to selection of
candidate genes and that would enable
bind mapping based on the analysis of
your different populations how effective
this integration in tomatoes I'm sorry
regression Tomatoes oh
it really it depends entirely on the
ancestor that you're looking at and so
it's pinellii uh
so ideally with integration lines you
want to generate individuals that have a
homozygous insertion in the genome
that's not possible with all the
ancestors like a persecutes is
particularly messy because it has self
incompatibility
um and also you you don't have perfect
matching of the chromosomes during
meiosis
so with you know with a relative that's
not so distant like pimpanellifolium
you'll be able to generate an
integration line population a problem
with panel AI no problem lycoprice
equities or something a little more
genetically distant uh going back to the
tree that would be a little bit more
challenging but still feasible you would
just have to deal with uh heterozygous
Integrations in some cases which still
have their value but it's a little uh
it's a little harder to interpret
foreign
yes that that could be a good approach
um
it's uh or alternatively it would be
also good to use a model similar to
rabbitopsis but that also displays soft
fruit because we are we're interested in
how and specifically how a lot of these
candidate genes mediate the progression
of ripening or parameters of the fruit
that you observe during ripening but
arabidopsis for a gene that also might
display of phenotype in the vegetative
phase that could be a that could be a
very good approach
have you seen ever any like feedback in
the pathway in a sense like depending on
what alleal you have at a gene could you
possibly have like lower total uh
amounts of like various compounds I'm
just curious because we've seen some of
that in Maize yeah
you've seen that also in tomatoes
um so just to make sure I understand the
crashing correctly you're talking so if
I have for instance higher fold
beta-carotene might I observe lower fold
accumulation of other pigments
provide noise yeah yeah
um that isn't something that I have
personally observed yet I probably will
in the future I will say actually that
the electrocutes isoforms of lycopene
beta cyclase those um
those are expressed at much lower fold
rpkm values in tomato and that actually
allows for accumulation of more Legacy
yeah
um and so it's I was actually I was
reading a paper last night talking about
how selection uh led to these genes with
low and fold Expressions so that you
would get red fruit yes it may was a
situation where we have lower activity
of frit Harvey one okay and that also
resulted in like uh lower amounts of
total parodoids which you wouldn't
expect so there's some kind of feedback
going on yeah
yeah it's um
Etc there's also the uh the interplay
between carotenoids and ethylene and
tomato
um which You observe in in some other
crops in some cases not it really runs a
spectrum but but yeah there does there
does seem to be in some cases of
feedback certainly between
um as you accumulate carotenoids and the
amount of flux going through the pathway
thank you everyone
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu